could be happy and then the one thing he
said that was actually that I just
chuckled to he said oh when um you want
your woman to have babies for you for
your legacy really truly like to be
honest with you it's usually women that
push to have kids more than guys bro
really you know I'm saying I don't know
about one of my ex-girlfriends she
wanted a kid bad and I had to just stop
sleeping with her because I was scared
she was gonna do that you know what I'm
saying so all of that is a joke then he
was like oh yeah
um when when you have a kid for your man
he wants you to lose all the weight in
30 days or less brav what are you
talking about you now you're just making
up nonsense like you're just making up
stories bro like and again just like you
said it's gonna cause more of a division
between women because the women because
he's saying stuff that he knows women
want to hear extremes extremes that is
going to make pump them up to feel like
yeah men are they are unreasonable
they're evil do you get what I'm saying
he's an idiot